we do have the U.S women's Junior
Champion Jennifer Yu is with us Jennifer
first of all congratulations a great
start for you two out of two yesterday
against Anna one of the rating favorites
that was a big battle tell us a bit
about that
well um I think like my technique there
in the end was definitely a bit
suspicious but overall I think it was a
pretty good game
um so they're in I wasn't really sure
like what my form would be coming into
this tournament
um just because like AR prep but you
always feel like you don't prep enough
and I've been really pretty busy with
like school I'm like still making up
everything
um so overall felt pretty good about it
I'm really happy the way it played in
the end I think I did some pretty
creative stuff
um but definitely a lot to work on too
let's talk about today's game uh when do
you feel like you're taking over it felt
like the position was complex but at
some point it just broke through
what was that key moment okay well to
start from the beginning this opening
was just I don't know the um
objective evaluation that something is
it definitely wasn't that good for me
but
um yeah so here I like I I knew I
definitely knew I was supposed to play
but um I didn't remember it right away
and then
um I don't know if you guys saw the
broadcast but I knew there was a camera
on me I was like coughing my lungs out
in the beginning
um so I wasn't feeling too good and I
was just like oh let me just make some
moves and then all of a sudden I'm like
what am I doing Bishop F39 better now
yeah
I'm just like it's just yeah I don't
know what's going on but um at some
point I think when I started to get um
like I moved my night a bunch of times
but when I got the Knight to F4 I
started to look um like I started to
have an initiative
like to have four nice maneuver
Target The Pawn on D5 Queen F6 which
would be Turkish Queen H5 okay so this
was like really tricky here
um because she played Rook C5 which I
think makes a lot of sense because now
um even though she like she's losing the
pawn she gets a lot a lot of how to play
for it
um so here I thought for a while we were
also both get a little lower on time I
think but here I was like okay we have
to go for this takes but it does look a
little scary here
um because G6 is nice and then create a
lift for uh the king first but there is
like the drawback that the king side
this weekend
um yeah now here yeah and Rook D2
um so I thought for a long time between
Queen B5 and queen F3 well Queen F3 I
just hated this move
I just I was like this is horrible but I
was like also a little bit scared about
um this birthday too because it just
looks so like black has so many tricks
after Queen B5 yeah but it seemed like
it didn't work like none of them worked
for her even though it was the best move
Queen B5 yeah it didn't work for her so
I went for this
especially after Queen C6 yeah can you
see six and and like you really want to
get Bishop takes E3 to work here but
you're supposed to C1 yeah so Bishop
takes C3 that's a nice one yeah of
course don't take on E3 because you get
checked mated
um and then here I think I'm just you
know
um I think she still has counter play
but uh it's like I don't think she has a
really obvious plan on how to continue
here no maybe this move Rook to E2 with
the idea to take on E3
take
Queen C3 and it gets pretty wild yeah I
go F6 but
wild position yeah it's just crazy and
how much time do you guys have at this
point five minutes for yourself and 13
minutes for her and actually she taught
for a very long time for this move Queen
F6
yeah here it just I think it completely
turns my favorite because now I'm
kicking her Rook back she can't really
um
like there's not that much like you know
her counter Play Chances are kind of
gone so yeah now it's just like very
easy for me
absolutely well
Jenny for a very strong start for you
two out of two what are your Ambitions
coming into this event
well I kind of had a very weird feeling
coming to this event because
um the last time I played this
tournament was
one person here 2019. I wanted 10 out of
11. so because of that it's like any
result other than 10 11 is kind of a
disappointment but obviously it's really
difficult and
um it's been a few years and
um I you know I haven't had as much time
to look at chess
um I just really wanted to like it's
play this tournament even though you
know it's not the most convenient time
for me except midterms and
um all sorts of things so
um I was just kind of like obviously I
want to win because that's my result
last time but I'm just kind of
you know as long as I like play well
keep up with my work you know I'm I can
I'll take it how do you usually combine
your academic career with playing chess
you study at Harvard right that's pretty
demanding yeah
yeah oh this is my first time missing
things in college
um so this is like I'm actually I'm
really learning that right now because I
used to do it in high school but it's
like completely different
um so you know I'm just have to put like
time out every day to watch lectures and
do readings like took a little quiz this
morning
um but you know so far so good I just
need to my other goal is to like sleep
because it was catchy that would be
um today
excellent congratulations Jennifer I
mean there's still planned actually not
11 rounds 13 Rounds yeah this year a lot
of games left to play congratulations
indeed our congratulations to you
Jennifer keep up by good work